be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we count down the top 5
characters teams and concepts from
across the comic book industry and this
week we're counting down the top 5
alternate realities and DC Comics number
5 journey's end written by Marv Wolfman
in 1994 and centered on the character of
Deathstroke the Terminator and this
reality Deathstroke finds his limited
healing ability keeps them alive well
into the 25th century with modern
society having crumbled under the
ruthless control of a race called the
genetics but in effect mutants
Deathstroke does what he can to attempt
to eliminate this race and restore
what's left of human society ticking on
a feeling very similar to Richard
Matheson's 1964 novel I am Legend the
origin of the genetics is found to be
due to the very experiment that gave
Deathstroke his abilities with the US
government looking to create the
physically perfect soldier that was also
controllable Slade Wilson was subjected
to the experimental program due to
initial bouts of insanity followed by
enhanced strength speed and endurance
but lacking the ability to be controlled
the government considered him to be a
failure continuing with their plan the
genetics were created and so with
humanity finding itself in a weakened
state following several global wars the
genetics took the opportunity to rise to
power and seize control of the planet
Earth number four
flashpoint as the catalyst for DC to
reboot their continuity and launch the
new 52 flashpoint presents us with a
dystopian society where the characters
of the DC Universe are reimagined in a
much darker way
what makes this universe so spectacular
and interesting among fans is that where
many of the Elseworlds stories Center on
one individual with appearances by other
characters to broaden the story this
reality seemingly focuses on and
dismantles the Justice League in its
entirety establishes villains as heroes
and turns the concept of the DC Universe
as we know it completely on its head as
one example one of my favorite aspects
on this story was that Bruce Wayne was
shot instead of his parents as a result
Thomas Wayne became a very ruthless
version of Batman and Martha Wayne
became the Joker furthermore rather than
being given a version of Superman that
is physically larger than life
and the flashpoint universe Superman was
captured immediately following his
arrival on earth and so without the
sunlight he's essentially an emaciated
and shrunken version of himself
continuing this trend by providing an
ongoing war between the Amazons and
Aquaman's Empire DC casts all existing
concepts aside bringing former friends
together as enemies and a battle that
would effectively in the world as we
know it number three
Superman red Sun written by Mark Miller
in 2003 Superman red Sun is considered
one of the best alternate realities in
existence centered on Superman raised by
Russians as opposed to Americans
Mark Miller wastes no time providing a
vastly different narrative than what
we're used to tying the arrival of
Superman to coincide with the Cold War
the Man of Steel is used as much by the
Russians for pro-soviet propaganda as
used by the Americans for anti-communist
sentiments while Superman argues that he
is a champion of the people much like
Michael Corleone and Mario Puzo's 1969
novel The Godfather
Superman plunges from his existence as a
hero trying to do the right thing to
becoming a dictator controlling the
minds of his citizens in an effort to
create a peaceful society what makes it
such a cool concept is that Mark Miller
asked the question if Superman stays on
righteousness a correct stance because
we genuinely agree with it or because it
happens to be the same position that we
have what I mean by this is that
Superman's belief of a peaceful world is
still a part of his character but rather
than changing the hearts and minds of
the people on earth he forces change on
its inhabitants by way of mind-control
devices but regardless of any
philosophical debates that maze is for
this story
the Superman red Sun is and always will
be considered a classic among the
Earth's world imprints and DC comic book
fans number 2 The Killing Joke while not
currently an alternate reality when it
was initially introduced by Alan Moore
in 1988 he was actually presented that
way focusing entirely on the Joker's
belief that all it takes is one bad day
to make someone insane The Killing Joke
is well known for several phase the
first is the origin of the Joker
while Alan Moore provides a full
backstory regarding who the Joker was
and how he became the iconic villain
then the same day in Alan Moore's
by way of the Joker admitting that he
doesn't fully recall his past that this
origin is not meant to be taken as an
absolute in addition to this The Killing
Joke is also known for the shooting and
possible sexual assault on Barbara
Gordon and Joker's effort to simply
drive Commissioner Gordon insane and
prove his point finally and probably the
most debated aspect of the story is the
ending without providing any true
conclusion the ending of The Killing
Joke has been argued by comic book fans
for years while some say the Batman went
insane at the end others say Batman
actually killed the Joker regardless of
what aiming people choose however The
Killing Joke had long lasting effects on
the bat family and the DC Universe
following its removal from an alternate
reality and its interjection into the
mainstream continuity one of the most
notable things at Killing Joke did was
provide a newfound purpose for Barbara
Gordon assured her into the spotlight
and even led many fans to believe that
the Joker's origins story as presented
here is the one true origin number one
Kingdom Come there's a reason why this
is one of the most celebrated stories
and alternate realities and existence
written by Mark Waid in 1994 and
centered on a combination of favorites
from the Golden Age and Silver Age of DC
Comics Kingdom Come provides us with a
view of DC's most iconic superheroes in
a vein similar to the Watchmen then this
reality the Joker murdered 93 people in
the Daily Planet
including Lois Lane and Jimmy Olsen
after being apprehended by authorities
before Superman could locate him
the Joker was executed prior to his
trial by Magog one of a new series of
self-proclaimed superheroes when Magog
was acquitted of his actions Superman
feeling as though society had lost its
understanding of justice decided to lead
the life of crime-fighting behind and
retire to a peaceful life following his
lead some of the most prominent heroes
of the time including Nightwing and
Green Lantern Alan Scott either retire
or went into seclusion but furthermore
with villains swiftly apprehended using
the new superhero style of a win at all
costs attitude their desire for conflict
drives them to turn on each other
plunging the United States and the world
into a state of total chaos with an
incident occurring in Kansas resulting
in the death of millions of people and
after being coaxed back in action by
Wonder Woman Superman leads a crusade
against the new generation of heroes in
a bad
they cost a life of shazam and almost
brings a world to the brink of total
destruction with that being said we're
going to go ahead and ring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I
will catch you guys later peace